just let me know when it's uh going
actually uh what you can you probably
could do the
countdown Zach says first oh he's here
okay good good we had a power routage
yeah for some reason like the power went
out yeah and then the router had to go
through I don't know if that had
anything to do with that that really
loud siren we heard earlier so got turn
some lights on I don't know what the
[__] happened Pooky doesn't know what
the [__] happened she's wandering around
going what the hell what happened what
happened we were going to we we left it
on for a little while to see if it would
come back on but it didn't seem to come
back on didn't seem to come back on so
we just stopped and started another one
so yeah yeah we had a power
outage I don't know what the [__]
happened that was the weirdest [__] ever
that was the weirdest [__]
ever all right everybody's piling back
in okay yeah sorry about that thank you
yeah power went
out I don't know why it's not storman or
anything like that it's just kind of
something happened something happened
somebody hit a Transformer or something
maybe I don't know what it was I don't
remember what we were talking about oh
press wrong button what are you doing
there turning the uh effects on oh
that's right
yeah yeah Ira said sometimes things
happen out of nowhere yeah they do
what's up PO what watch out she's right
behind
you she's trying to see what Daddy's up
to yeah she doesn't understand it yeah
she's like um what the hell happened
with this I don't
know oh now it won't come on green no
it's on but can't change the color oh
yeah we want to go back to the blue so
you can see it everybody still coming
back in yeah yeah yeah Tammy came back
Jeffy art came back Iris came back why
can't Zach says turn blue okay that's
not the same blue though we had like a
lighter blue like a teal there you go
that's
it um Alison said I blame the
cat yeah maybe Zach says uh you want to
hear some [__] I got a ride back
from the synagogue last month at like
9:00 p.m. and it was $54 back home how
far was
that because that is some [__]
$54 I can't afford to be paying that
although I will say that I got the um
the bill for the tolls yeah for going to
momentum Waring stuff that [__] was like
$19.64 just for one night I don't know
no that had been like a month maybe it
no it wasn't a month's worth but maybe
it was two Journeys all right they do
charge more if you do pay no you don't
have to if you do pay by plate they do
charge more um but I don't see I can't
really justify like having the sun pass
because we don't use it enough you know
the only time we use that is when we go
to Barbarella that's the only time we
use the toll road like so you if you go
to downtown Sanford you don't have to
Zach said it was only 12 miles it was 12
miles and it was $54 damn all right [__]
that might as well just
walk 12 miles isn't that far it's not
that far you could do it in like three
hours
maybe I'm going through the this chick's
pictures let me show you guys go back to
what we were talking about we were
talking about how how many people got in
there now I don't know you can see it I
can't
okay get a few more I can only see the
chat I can't see the number of people
that are in there somebody could
probably type it in they could probably
see see how many's in
there we had a power
outage
yeah in case you're just joining us
again
yeah did I put part two on the [__] oh I
think I forgot to that's okay I can do
it later
16 says K yeah yeah yeah okay okay I
think it was in the 20s before well
that's okay some people like had to I
was saying look Mig over look at how
awesome these kids look nowadays man we
would have killed to have that [__] back
in the 0 I looked like that in the
[__] 8s and that's like I didn't have
all that that's like 83 to uh I don't
know you probably saw that as late as
latest the uh mid
90s but um that would have that would
that been like top not [__] you'd have
to spend [__] a [__] ton of money to
get that back in the 80s and the 90s
yeah
yeah like I said they're kind of and
it's easy to find lucky in a lot of ways
they're real lucky they don't realize it
though me look how look how [__] what
are you doing on oh thank you very much
Bryce thank you very much for the Super
Chat just tuned in happy to be here yeah
we had another stream going but we lost
power so we had to start over had a
power outage yeah look how cute that
chick is look at those [__]
clothes what year would you put that at
it's homaging but maybe again May
87 something like that maybe a little
bit earlier but yeah 84 to 87 but see I
love that so like I said you even go to
mannequins and you see like these people
in their 20s and they look like that
yeah and it's just like they don't even
like any of the new [__] they don't like
um you know any the ebm or anything like
that they're just kind of like but man
they play Susie and the Banshees or some
[__] like that man those [__] are all
out there all right soar wanted me to
show this to you he says can you show
this Jen this book I think you and her
will like it it's about the relation
between the Manson and the CIA oh right
and the possibility that they were
handling him I only just started reading
it this is the book that's
s
chaos yeah that might be
interesting
okay Tammy says today is my daughter's
birthday she's 31 damn I feel old damn
don't feel feel too old I could also
have a daughter that was 31 but I don't
but I
could uh Zach also says uh so how
pathetic is it I'm still crushing on the
Gibb
brothers that's not pathetic that's
fine it is funny to me though because
they just they they're so 70s to me with
the hair and everything I tell you what
man VG's their sound was tight it was
very tight I appreciate them a lot more
than I did back then I will admit that
yeah okay they're um yeah Tammy said
she's 55 right yes you're only a couple
years older than I am you're only a year
older that time not that no I'm that age
I think no you're 5 you're 54 you'll be
55 in July of 2021 that's
right and I turned
51 last September so like a couple
months ago how come we can't see the
plaque behind you you moved that's what
it is
I didn't or did I move the camera you
moved the camera is happened how could I
no I didn't move the camera yeah you did
you were [__] around with it I
remember what did I
do good Lord Tom what are you doing it
wasn't way over there it wasn't no I
mean it doesn't matter just leave it
somewhere Center okay that's good you
can see it now I mean that wasn't where
it was but it doesn't matter I don't
care you I didn't
move yeah yeah youve there see there you
go there you go I didn't move you moved
I got it to go to the bathroom but I
didn't move the you came back out you
moved then here hold on whatever hold
hold on there you go see okay okay he's
always got a [__] micro adantage
Allison says I'll be 56 in January I'm
[__] old
people like I said we're old too so yeah
well that's well that's probably why we
have like a lot of um people that come
in the chat and like come see the shows
and stuff like that is they're the same
age as us so they can relate you know
what I mean yeah
overgrown children they grew up the same
as well well like I said I kind of feel
like Our Generation generation x yeah
we're not
really we didn't really play by a lot of
the rules yeah we're not really aging
the same much as people aged in the past
I guess what is that Meme that's going
around I think I sent it to you well we
knew it was kind of [__] yeah the
one that said Generation X are the only
uh generation that were 30 years old at
10 years old and are still 30 years old
at years old and I was like accurate
that's
accurate and Allison says I have no idea
what I want to be when I grow up I don't
either really when I grow up I want to
be an
airplane yeah I love that I love that
you wanted to be an airplane yeah when I
was a little kid they used to ask me
what I wanted to be when I grew up I was
like five or six as I want to be an
airplane nobody's like uh you me want to
fly an airplane I no I want I want be an
air be an airplane yeah I love that yeah
that's so
cute you were such a cute child tingle
would
understand he's got a whole sub genre of
erotica based on that very concept
billionaire airplane
boyfriend and there's probably some
dinosaurs in there
dinosaurs I was just watching a video um
from uh zrank who does all those really
funny like nature videos and he made a
comment in there what did he say he said
something like
um adulting is like improv but not the
funny kind I was just like yeah pretty
much Zach says I'll be 27 in March yeah
you could pretty
much he could be my kid couldn't he yeah
yeah you could be my kid isn't that
weird not really probably no not really
I don't really think of it as weird cuz
we have friends that we have friends
that could be our kids we have kids we
have friends that could be our grandkids
probably well I told you it weirded me
out a little bit because I was talking
to Michael from aari night and he told
me that he was born in 1990 yeah and
like I it had never really occurred to
me that he was I knew he was younger but
I it didn't occur to me he was that much
I'm like dude it's like I graduated from
high school in 1990 I was like I could
be your mom when I got out of the army
he was
four and he's like yeah it's that right
and I was just kind of like oh my God I
never thought of it but then I don't
really think about it anymore it's like
I don't know it's not weird it's funny
it's not weird
Zack said if you guys were my parents I
probably wouldn't have near as many
issues as I do maybe not I kind of feel
like in some alternate
universe where we had kids I don't know
like they either would have been like
super cool or they would have been like
[__] up Beyond they would have been
lame recognition you think they would
have been lame probably that was one of
the reasons I really didn't want to have
kids because I just was kind of like
worried that they would be super lame
they've been normies that light is very
very bright they revert to the mean yeah
and it's just that that kind of bothered
me I mean there were a lot of other
reasons I didn't want to have kids
either but I mean that was one of the
main ones I was like man what if I have
one and they're
like they're lame yeah they come out and
they're like you know we know people in
the scene that are like
that the parents are [__] freaky as
[__] they're funny the kids are just are
just normal as [__] yeah and they're
like looking at the parents like you
guys are weirdo they leave never come
back it's just like I'm like it's so
funny yeah because like I said a lot
country west a lot of people in our in
the scene are our age and so a lot of
them have kids and a lot of them have
kids that are grown yeah some of the
kids are cool but like some of the kids
are just kind of like they're like the
opposite of the yeah they're like the
opposite and I was kind of afraid that
that's what would happen like if I ever
had
any kayin hickin said I still love that
study that ask men if they think they
can fly a plane with no training and a
majority said yes
that does not surprise me at all I'm
sure they can fly can you land it that's
the thing well see yeah that's maybe
that's kind of the distinction I didn't
land it
though cuz that's kind of the more
important thing yeah like yeah you could
probably fly a plane if you had to but
getting it back down on the ground like
without killing everyone that's a whole
other it depends on the plane yeah a big
jetliner you're going to have problems
Landing that you
know um
but you know my Dad could fly Cessna and
he let me
fly I didn't land it just flew
[Laughter]
it and
uh once you get the handle handle of you
will get it on the ground okay one way
or the other you get it on the
ground you'll probably survive that
plane won't you'll tear that [__]
plane all up and you'll probably put
yourself in the
hospital I've seen action cams of guys
wrecking ultralight aircraft you know
and [__] I'm like man this dude's
going to die I mean this [__] You'
seen it from his point of view and that
[__] thing's rolling and and I'm like
man what how are those wings spars
holding
together because the wings SP on a
ultral light is not very strong I mean
you know it's only meant to go forward
really you know and this thing's [__]
doing rolls and [__] going straight down
to the ground I'm like man he's going to
try to pull out of that and it's going
to [__] snap those wings
SPS he didn't though he got out of his
problems and uh he got into a
spin got out of it and landed it on the
nearest thing which was a road like a
highway that was underneath him and he
was [__] in bricks when he landed it I
also would be so can't blame him but I
was like amazed that he made it I
thought I was like man I was like man
they must have took this action cam off
of him after he died it did wck it did
wreck it [__] the wings all up and
everything but he he survived it was he
messed up or was he un no he was okay oh
okay he's okay but didn't break any it
was all bent up you know but those an
ultral light is not that expensive you
know you can fix
it and uh he got out of that [__]
spin it was amazing but you could he was
screaming again he was screaming during
all that I don't blame him for that not
one bit yeah he was trying to stay cool
you
know I don't you know what I don't I
don't begrudge anybody you think you're
going to crash in a plane and you don't
really know what you're doing and you
can just scream and [__] yourself and
stuff like that I don't think anybody's
going to judge you I'm not going to he
doing what he I think he lost flow over
his control surfaces because the control
surfaces weren't responding I really
couldn't tell what if it was some kind
of flat spin or what kind of spin it
was but he got it right he eventually
got some air flow over the control
services and regained control but it was
he was real close to the ground when he
when he fin finally got control and he
basically just belly flopped it onto a
[__] I just onto a [__] road there
wasn't any cars around or anything two
lane highway just belly flopped it it
just
crushed but it all absorbed the shock
when it crumpled right and he got out of
there and he had a camera on his helmet
you know cuz they're kind of dressed in
something kind of like motorcycle gear
in a way you know a helmet on and
everything and he runs out of it he's
[__] screaming and yelling looking
back at the wreck and he's goes I made
I made it I made it you [__] yeah lucky
[__] again I would also be doing
that lucky [__] oh my God I
should go get a lottery tick in yeah
that's kind of what I would be think
yeah and he was several thousand feet in
the air I just really hope that I am
never put in that situation yeah because
I'm saying right now it's like I would
probably like [__] flip the [__] out
I don't know maybe if I was in that kind
of situation I'd be like oh my God I'm
going to figure this out but I'd just
kind of feel like I'd be like and I
would just be like oh well I'm just
going to crash yeah he wasn't a new guy
he was experienced right you know so you
never know like until an experienced
person yeah cuz even like well yeah like
even people that are um that are
experienced with that situation or have
been trained in that situation I mean
everybody can freeze up you know what I
mean he wasn't freezing at least he was
screaming and trying to get back he was
trying to do whatever he had to do
trying to get air flow back
over I believe oh my God nothing was
responding
it was just that's another one of my
worst nightmares falling and spinning
and none of his controls were responding
like I said and I said this on the main
animal show on Wednesday night I said
one of my worst ways to die is like
being eaten by a shark or a crocodile
also in my top five being in a plane
crash no thanks no thanks I really do
not like flying planes it didn't used to
bother me until I was on a really really
really bad flight to London one time
that had like horrible turbulence like
the whereas like you know plane dropped
hundreds of feet in the air and like
[__] like that yeah no thanks I love
them no thanks I know I know you do
especially helicopters man we used to
have so much fun in the [__] Choppers
Man flying nap of the earth over [__]
Korea looking out and I'm watching the
rotor blades actually hit the hit the
limbs of those Korean pine trees that's
how F close we were that [__] blade
will go right through the pine tree just
the tops you know cuz they're not very
big things is [__]
amazing and uh doors open none of that
door closed [__] strapped in it's fun
[__] when you were really jabbing
you're like 150 M hour win 200 knots
something like that I think their top
speed like 200 knots you're probably
going about 130
140 I like being in a motorcycle kind of
it's wild man I liked it it's a
different sensation than
airplane airplanes are real predictable
[__] hell Shoppers are all over the
place man I know what you're talking
about about that inter turbulance when
you dip I mean the thing about it a
helicopter might not bother me as much
yeah um one they don't go as high so
that's one thing um they go pretty high
well I know but not as high as an
airplane yeah like a like a 747 would um
and I don't know like you said it's a
different experience I kind of feel I
kind of feel like the problem I have
with planes is that my imagination
starts taking over and it's like yeah it
seems like it's just going woo but it's
like so I always have to like tell
myself that it's like well I'm just on a
bus I'm on the ground I'm on the ground
I'm on the ground because if I think
that I'm like way up in the air in this
little [__] metal tube it like freaks
me the [__] out and I start having a
panic attack if you're Air Assault
infantry or Airborne infantry and you're
flying to
Choppers it's snap of the earth
especially if it's a night the [__]
Pilots are using
nvgs it's like riding a roller coaster
cuz you're going up mountains over the
top of them so you're going to pull a
lot of negative G jez you know and
sometimes they're doing the same route
over and over again just to get just to
get put in hours and they're having fun
pulling negative G's diving down the
other side of the hill or the mountain
you know and [__] you're leaving your
seat [__] you got all your weapon you
know at the time I was an M60 Gunner I'm
carrying the 60 my helmet [__] going
up wind the doors are open so winds
blowing
in wind to blow in and catch your k-pot
helmet and [__] be like a parachute
be pulling your like that you're trying
to stick your chin out to tighten up
your chin strap your helmet doesn't blow
off there's all kinds of wild [__] that
were doing but most of the time it was
just normal flying straight and hovering
and going across a gulf you know a gulf
of aaba when you're in in in in um uh si
in
Egypt fun [__] Zach says imagining
entirely goth families is a really
amusing thought to me yeah goth families
it does happen though yeah party at
their houses yeah yeah well just like
any other it would be just like any
other subculture or whatever you want to
call it like the parents are into the
[__] they like sometimes the kids get
into the [__] sometimes they don't like
sometimes they go off on their own thing
yeah but you'd be surprised how many
times the kids are actually into the
[__] yeah and then they show up the club
yeah we have well are there yeah we had
that happen um in one particular case uh
they're a little younger than us but
they have a couple kids that are
grown and one of them I think she just
is off toing Normy [__] I don't think
I've ever even met her maybe one time
but their younger kid was really into
goth [__] when she was a
Preen and then in her teenage years she
was kind of like [__] that [__] you guys
are weirdos blah blah blah and she went
off and did something else but then when
she got to be about 17 18 19 years old
she's like oh this is kind of cool and
now she starts like now she comes to to
the clubs which I thought was like super
funny yeah they're all talking about
kids yeah the thing about it is that
like I said I never wanted them I have
three siblings my brother who is four
years younger than me and his wife have
four kids two of them are theirs and two
of them are hers from a previous
relationship they're all pretty much
grown now I never even thought of them I
I didn't really either um and my two
younger siblings uh you know my sister
has you know been in a relationship with
a long time boyfriend and um my brother
is
married um neither of them seem
particularly interested uh in having
children I don't know if they might at
some point but I don't know I I just
kind of feel like probably not I was
having so much fun I never even thought
of it yeah it's just kind of like when I
was younger I was like nah it's just it
never seemed like it was for me you know
what I mean like I said some people love
that [__] and it's like they want to do
that stuff but it's like I just never I
don't have that Gene I couldn't imagine
it now I don't have that Jee I don't
have the energy anymore I couldn't
imagine it well that's what I mean and I
told my mom that like when I was younger
I was like I'm pretty sure that I wasn't
born with that whatever that thing is
that like people have that makes them
want kids I'm like I I don't have that
yeah I don't have that um and I I think
she thought that I would change my mind
later but I never did I never did I just
we were always busy well by the time me
and Jen hooked up we were already beyond
the age really I mean I was already I
met you I was what 38 yeah and I was
[__]
39 I was about 42 41 right and the thing
about it is like I married second on our
second marriage yeah I mean I married
when I was in my early 20s and me and my
ex-husband talked about it for like a
minute and then we were kind of like n
he's like and I was kind of like
yeah you know what I mean we just like
just I was like I never even thought
about it and he wasn't really like jazz
about it either so I'm just kind of like
just caught the live stream for the
first time yeah oh really oh okay sorry
I'm way behind yeah way behind where was
that uh hey there's John Smith John
Robertson hey guys finally made a live
stream I started school for a pharmacy
technician and I've been busy lately oh
we have a friend that does that um I
also started the novel slooh foot and I
heard uh Jenny talking about it it's
good so far yeah I'm about a quarter of
the way through it I want to do a review
of it but it's just kind of like I don't
want to rush through it but I really
need some more time to read you know
what I mean tomorrow when we wake up
we're going to go uh to the uh Chinese
buffet and pig out across the street
they got a uh AMC Theater we're gonna
see Godzilla zero all right or is it or
minus one minus one that's minus one
Godzilla minus one see you only told me
that one time and I remember yeah she
remembered I forgot CU I'm smart
everybody's saying it's great it's a
Japanese Godzilla movie I saw the
trailer it looks pretty cool yeah it's
not an American one evidently I think
they said it's a Japanese one and they
said it's the best Godzilla movie since
the original they said it's [__]
great great and it was a cheap movie
only $15 million budget but they said it
was just done right the CG is awesome
it's not a I think it might be a Toho
movie but I don't think it has the
suit you know I think it's
CG if I based on what they said I
haven't seen it but they said it's the
best movie of this year yeah we might go
see it tomorrow yeah i' like to see it's
probably they got a show their show the
first show was at 1:10 okay we'll just
remember that we'll we'll try to get up
early yeah or we can see the second one
too yeah cuz I was like if we're going
out tonight I don't know how that's I
don't know how that's going to play out
we might sleep until noon I don't know I
don't know godilla movie man they say
it's [__] just fun yeah that might be
fun it's like watching the mag or
something that might be fun yeah but um
let what else was I to say oh they
dropped the uh first trailer for furiosa
yeah I heard today is it good yeah it
looks pretty good it looks pretty good
it's going to be when's it coming out I
don't know it was just like a teaser
trailer it'll probably be pretty good I
mean I would imagine it's George Miller
right how can he can't [__] that up come
on um yeah he's got that cute chick
being fosa right what's her name an
Taylor Joy yeah yeah that girl's so cute
she is she's adorable yeah I just like
her she gives off a lot of good energy
she's been in some great [__] movies
too she was in that great no time to die
too yeah she's been she's been a [__]
she was in [__] Blade Runner she's in
a [__] yeah no that was um I saw the
same girl no that's Anor armas oh okay
which one is this then Anna Taylor Joy
she was in I remember her from the she
was in the witch right I didn't see it I
don't think you saw that I guess I
didn't see it you might like it you I
thought it was that girl from Blade
Runner and and um no that's a different
jick yeah what's her name again they do
sort of look like right Anna D armis
Anna D armas that's who I thought it was
yeah yeah yeah it'd be great if it was
her Anna oh Anna Taylor Joy was
in last night in
SoHo okay yeah she's pretty good last
night in SoHo yeah she starred in it
right yeah yeah yeah yeah that was her
that's her yeah she's good she's good
that was a great movie I love that movie
that was a good movie I feel like nobody
talks about that and it's just kind it's
Edgar Wright and I mean he's that was a
good ghost [__] right yeah I really lik
that movie I think they I think it's on
I think it's on um you can watch it for
free now I think on Amazon Prime or
something like that I mean I think we
reviewed it when it first came out cuz
guys want to see a [__] sexy [__]
ghost movie with a lot of dark [__] in
it that's the one you want to see what
was it called again last night in SoHo
last night in SoHo I a British it's a
British period click it's happening in
London like in the' 60s I really liked
it parts of it yeah it kind of goes back
and forth modern day to like the' 60s
yeah um Allison said I'm too selfish for
kids see I think a lot of people say
that I don't think it's selfishness
necessarily you know what I mean I just
kind of feel like I was working on other
projects all the time that's what I mean
I just always kind of felt like I had
other [__] I had to do and then the
money that too they're very expensive
yeah so although people that have them
so they're not that expensive you just
[__] pop them out [__] just give
them something they'd be all right and
then they're out of here well they're
still expensive yeah yeah I don't know
we know a lot of poor people that have
them but maybe they poor because they
have I mean [__] well yeah that's what
that's probably the I mean [__] we've
got cats and even that's expensive like
buying all that stuff buying food and
litter and all that kind of stuff so I
can imagine like it must be a million
times more expensive than to have
[__] kids
um the oh hang
on uh Camp guy said my daughter had a
[__] boyfriend for a long time but then
she got rid of him for good and now is
married to a real man I'm so glad she
got away from that loser yeah that's
good John Smith said my mother and
father were kind of old when I was born
40 and 55 wow yeah John Robertson said I
never had the desire to have kids but my
siblings are 12 years younger than me so
they're technically my kids or they seem
like it anyway yeah I mean I have
younger siblings but they're not like my
brother's 4 years younger my sister is 7
years younger and then my other brother
is 14 years
younger okay so uh what time do we have
to end the show around 9:30 probably 9
or 9:30 so we still we still got like an
hour got about an hour so we're good
yeah Bryce says it might also be
cultural if you come from a culture that
is all about having kids it might be
different Americans seem to be more
about individual Freedom which I like
yeah I kind of feel like it's sort of
left up to you like people do do still
probably not so much nowadays but people
do still kind of look a scance at you
it's like if you don't have kids but I
don't know I don't I don't think they
really do that much anymore because
you're just kind of like I don't really
want to have kids and everybody's like
okay you know what I mean America's kind
of a genetic meat grinder you come here
your chances are you're not going to
reproduce especially if you go to uh an
urban area you're going to be too busy
you know and it's always been that way
you move to a big city you not have kids
you're like well you're having too much
fun your bills your bills are high yeah
I mean you know yeah and you're you're
probably not dating much
um having kids was more of a suburban
and uh rural thing you can get away with
more that that's over the past 200 years
this 200 and something years this place
has been
here yeah I just I don't know like I
said it's just they got all that time on
their hands they're not in the rat
race and you have children they go well
we had one and that one runs off you
know joins the army or something like I
said and some people and some people
[__] love kids man my mom loves kids
she had four of her own uh she came from
a family where she had seven brothers
and sisters and she ran a daycare yeah
she just couldn't get enough of them
yeah some people like them and I was
like like I said I I did not get that
Jean that's for sure some wom just built
that way I did not get that jeene
yeah and I told her that before I'm like
you know no offense but I didn't get
that um yeah cuz I just from my cuz I
you know I grew up like surrounded by a
lot of kids and I was just kind of like
man this is annoying as [__] I don't
like I don't want to spend the rest of
my life doing this crap I was an only
child so I was the I was the kid yeah I
didn't give a [__] about kid it's so
interesting to me because it's just kind
of like I've hung out with a lot of
people that were only children it's just
kind of like that must be so weird well
it's not weird to you obviously because
that's the only thing that's you don't
know any different but it's just kind of
like the
whole the whole um only child versus
people with siblings then cuz I have
three siblings so it's just kind of like
it's an entirely different experience
entirely different so yeah I mean from
what I know like of talking to people
that were only children and I was just
like that's it's so different I didn't
even think of it yeah well like I said
you wouldn't because it's like you
didn't like I don't I don't know what it
would be like to grow up as an only
child because I was only and only child
for the first four years of my life and
then my brother was born so I don't
really remember you know anything about
it John Smith said Tom's life ambition
to make sure every all you can eat
buffet loses money when he's a patron
[__] right I'm gonna go make you pay
for that [__] I'm g go right with the
shrimp go right to that book was that a
joke all you can eat jokes on them yeah
yeah I'm going go right to that Shrimp
start tearing that shrimp up
we're famous there now the waitress the
waitress and the wait we go there almost
every weekend hey how you
doing got a got a Chinese waitress that
knows us she she got a cute booty too
and her boyfriend works there and they
playing grab ass behind the [__]
that's Jenny he's grabbing her ass and
we caught him one time caught grabb his
and they still remember that yeah two
Chinese people it was very funny yeah CH
Chinese woman cuz he was all like G
grabbing and I was just like oh my god
look how cute she's giggling cuz they're
like super young yeah and I was like a
look at that they're not super young
they're probably in their 30s I mean
they're adorable though like the two of
them and it's just it was just like
funny that every time we go there they
just so she like Giggles every time she
gigles she SE yeah cuz she knows that we
caught her and her boyfriend like grab
playing grab she's grabbing that ass she
does have a cute little butt though yeah
she got a cute little butt Tom made me
look at it yeah look at that
ass Chinese girls don't have the ass
that ass she's got it it pops out it's a
bubble
butt that that's kind of rare yeah yeah
in in in the Far East they have it but
it's rare more rare he was noticing well
clear he was noticing it yeah he was
grabbing
it like not right on the floor or
anything but it was kind of like behind
the in the waitress station yeah and
they had they they had a little wall
there and there was a little bit of a
curtain but it curtain wasn't full and
they were running around and I saw him I
saw his hand he grabb he's running from
him giggling giggling he's back there
grabbing that ass sound then they come
out come out pretend like nothing
happened smile I'm like I saw it she's
laughing she was grabbing my ass he's
like yeah we saw that yeah so it's like
now every time we come back she kind of
like giggles at us
yeah uh John says I also came out as gay
so everyone was like okay we'll stop
asking for kids and grandkids see that's
another thing that's another thing let's
see oh I got way behind on the comments
Zach said I can't believe it's been
almost nine years since Fury Road came
out that is [__] crazy yeah that's
bizarre
yeah I hope he doesn't let me down I
hope that's a good movie should be it'll
be a good movie I'm not worried about it
he said when he dies he's gonna hand it
over he's gonna hand it over to some
guys that were going to do real good
with
it yeah some younger guys that know that
know what he was what he's into what the
story is
about it's like you don't want to hand
Star Wars over to Disney you know mean
which they learned that
mistake they learned from that mistake
Tammy says I think it's more selfish
that some people have kids only because
they want to show them off like some
kind of dress up doll yeah I've always
thought that too that's why I don't
think it's inherently selfish to not
want to have children because I think
some people just have children like you
said for selfish reasons you know yeah
sometimes you'll have single girl who
has nothing going for a life she just
wants to get pregnant so she can have a
living
doll yeah I mean and we've known some
people like
too so
yeah and you know some people have kids
it's just like oh they want a mini me
yeah you know what I mean which is
that's [__] up that's another person
like you can't impose your [__] on them
you know what I mean well you got to
guide them sure I'm not saying that but
I'm just saying that you kind of have to
let them find their own way that's a
different person than you yeah well you
get older yeah
yeah but you still kind of got to guide
them especially if it's especially if
it's a boy they're [__] dumb
[Laughter]
boys are dumb that's well you got have
an adult male to go you don't do that
I'll beat your [__] ass no
disagreement for me yeah the girls
aren't quite so
dumb that's true yeah in general it's
hormones yeah
yeah at least you realize
it teenage boys got to be kept in check
yeah you really gota like well they'll
just run they'll just [__] run a muck
yeah
Bryce says uh I always avoid babysitting
friends kids because I got too many of
my own he said he had four which some of
them were you know
ex-girlfriends and stuff like that but
Alison said I liked a babysit him I
don't even like to babysit him I said
you know I know this is maybe going to
be controversial but I don't really like
children you know I just
don't they've I don't they've always
just been I I don't like anything that
like makes a a bunch of noise and it's
just kind of like well babies and stuff
yeah that's what I I don't like babies
either yeah I don't like I said I don't
have that Gene you know what I mean I
know I know it's kind of like um a thing
where it's like oh somebody brings a
baby and it's like all the ladies are
like Oh and it like yeah I don't do that
I don't like babies I'm like yeah you
just keep that over there that stinky
little screaming whatever I'm just like
you just keep that over there away from
me thank
you Tammy said Red Lobster lost a lot of
money from their all the all you can eat
your shrimp special oh I was reading an
article about that the other day yeah
well they decided cuz you know how they
used to have what what I don't remember
what they called it but endless shrimp
or whatever they called it endless
shrimp and they would usually just do
that seasonally or just kind was like it
was a special event they decided to
start doing it all the time like as a
loss leader they knew they were going to
lose money on it but they thought it
would bring more money into the
restaurant um but I think it ended up
costing them more than they thought cuz
everybody's like okay they wereing
challenge accepted yeah and like went in
there and like ate all the [__] so I can
go into that Chinese
buffet and me and Jen will be the only
people actually getting those shrimp
most people and very few people get get
the Crawfish there's crawfish sitting
there yeah but I like crawfish but I
don't like those crawfish they're not
seasoned yeah they're a little Bland
they're too bland you know I like
zeran's [__] seasoning in there it's
got to be hot real hot crawfish and they
also the Crawfish themselves had I don't
like cold crawfish that much I like them
to be
hot but
um that [__] what's the name of that
place uh ich bun ichan yeah it's not as
it's not as nice as Kian but it's not as
far either like kiwan is kind of fire
five miles farther in another
Direction the traffic's a lot worse I
still want to go back there
though but uh well if you want to drive
and pay for gas we can go there tomorrow
if you want I want to see the movies oh
that's right we got to go to yeah but uh
the ich what's good about ichon is is it
it has it has real good [__] pot
stickers the dumplings there's a lot of
stuff that's good there I mean they it's
just not as fancy right it's not as
fancy they don't seem to be suffering
though cuz man just packed we went there
we didn't go last Saturday we went
Sunday cuz we didn't go anywhere
Saturday and that place was heaving it
was just it was full yeah it's like it
was hard to get any food cuz everybody's
just Milling around all the [__] you
know what I mean they're tearing it up
in there holy crap I think it's because
Sunday they give you like the dinner
stuff like all day but for the same
price as the lunch stuff I know I think
we got lunch price booty girl gave us
lunch price Maybe yeah I think so I
thought that was the deal it was dinner
all day that's why yeah dinner all day
but it not for the lunch Price Right for
for dinner price which isn't it's not
like a huge difference the only reason
that that's it well no I'm saying like
the as far as the food goes I think they
have more out like they have like um
roast beef instead of ham roast be like
a few I did noticed they didn't have any
egg fu young though they didn't did they
no cuz I went to get some and they
didn't have any I don't always get it
but
we actually eat health food at the
Chinese restaurant well I don't eat any
carbs we don't eat any carbs we don't
eat any noodles any rice no rice no
noodles we just eat meat I just eat meat
and and vegetables yeah I'll eat I'll
eat a couple of pot stickers that's got
a little bit of want like I'll have
fruit for a dessert yeah fruit and then
I'll eat some ice cream I don't even
have any ice cream and I can eat ice
cream I want
steroids I'll burn that [__] up but I'm
eating mostly just protein meat and
sauce I'm smart man I'm not going to go
to fill up with that [__] but man
sometimes I'll break down I will eat a
slice of pizza from the Chinese
restaurant it's the weirdest pizza ever
but there's something just good about it
is kind of good though there just
something kind of good about it like it
doesn't taste cheese bread yeah it
doesn't taste exactly like a pizza it's
almost like it's steamed it's like it's
steamed it's light and fluffy but it's
like a light and fluffy cheese bread
it's really good yeah yeah it's but I
would call it pizza so sometimes it is
pizza sometimes it's got a crispy crust
on the bottom it depends on who cook I
guess but it's like it's really funny
because sometimes I'll be sitting at the
table and like he'll come back and he's
got like a piece of the little piece I'm
looking like I'm all guilty that's all
carbs that's all carbs he'll give me a
bite of it sometimes but it's like I
don't I don't usually get that and the
cheese is like a four mix Mexican cheese
blend right so it's got cheddar on it
yeah like I said it's weird but but it's
still it's like it's kind of good though
it's good yeah in a weird way although I
don't know if I'd necessarily call it
pizza cheese bread it's kind of more
like cheese bread but there's nothing
wrong with that yeah I mean you know it
it has some tomato sauce on it but
there's no
toppings yeah it's just cheese and a
little bit of sauce and it's and it's
kind of pillowy yeah yeah it's fluffy
it's kind of pillowy and fluffy yeah so
it's almost yeah it's almost more like a
almost like a bun bread like a bun bun
yeah like a steamed bun but it's kind of
good though yeah which is weird I don't
like I said I don't usually get it but I
usually get the same thing I get shrimp
I get vegetables I get uh broiled fish
yeah and fish is good I get a bunch of
mushrooms yeah sa mushroom then I get
some like a little bit of chicken with
broccoli yeah sometimes egg fu young if
they have it yeah and that's about it
they have uh all the sweet and sour
stuff they'll have the deep fried they
have [__] chicken wings there oh and
sometimes I'll get a chicken thigh like
on
they got chicken wings there and they
have [__] blue cheese dressing so you
can make a whole chicken wing plate if
you wanted to uh you could it's not just
Chinese food it's anything you want too
bad y'all don't live here we'd all meet
up at the Chinese restaurant I mean I
feel like they're all kind of we have
like 50 of us at the Chinese restaurant
we just take that [__] over that would
be fun that'd be [__] funny everybody
should yeah we're ich then in Le was it
Le it's in leberg leberg it's in it's in
front of the lak Square Mall yeah in
front of the it is country as across
from the rubb and tug yeah it's although
turns out it's not they're not rubbing
or tug they're rubbing but they're not
tugging every day they're we were
because we make jokes about it every
single time they're tring to go there
Jenny let's go get a rub and tug cuz I
was like Tom are you sneaking up here
and getting rub and tug like when I'm
not like around or something like that
no I'd go to the Oriental spa if I was
going to do that that's in the other
they're doing it
there okay you better tell me about it
after don't be doing that [__] behind my
back but yeah I'll bring you with me
You' be table next you both be getting
it so I was like so I got curious enough
to like look up the Yelp reviews and
from the Yelp reviews it didn't seem it
seemed like it was like just a legit
yeah place that didn't CU nobody made
any like weird inuendos or anything like
that cuz that's kind of what I was
looking for yeah some of them have
inuendos you know one of the dis I'm
always happy when I'm when I leave the
ending is always you know yeah then you
know what's going on there so I always
kind of Wonder well we always make a
joke because when we pass because it's
right there like across the street and
there's hard there's hardly anybody in
the parking lot well yeah like I looked
it up because I was like well how much
is it to like get a and they said like a
couple's massage yeah and like some most
of the reviews were from women actually
yeah and they said yeah we got a
couple's massage like for Valentine's
Day or whatever and um what would what
did I say it was something 60 yeah it
was like 80 130 or was like no I think
it was yeah I think it was 80 bucks each
80 bucks each yeah but it was like an
hour long or 90 minutes and they said so
I mean that's not that unreasonable for
that amount of time and then it's like a
lot of people were like oh my God it was
amazing they did like hot rocks and all
that other kind of stuff so I just like
they just do regular [__] um I didn't
really see any reviews on there that
hinted to me that they were doing like
some sketchy [__] because they do have
that which we know a girl that worked in
one of those places well yeah and and I
think that the distinction being I think
that you have to look if the people
working there are masseuses yeah then
yeah then it's going to be like a Rubin
tug if it's a massage therapist that's a
different that's a whole different thing
you know what I mean we just kind of
like to joke about it because yeah cuz
nobody's ever in the parking lot and I
was just kind of like wonder about it
yeah it'll be open nobody in the parking
lot and the parking lot next to it's
filled yeah we're always like oh those
dudes are all parking over everybody's
going over there like cheating on their
wives like getting getting hand jobs
yeah like over they're probably not but
I mean we like to entertain ourselves in
that way John Robertson said hey Jenny I
found a book you would like it's psycho
sanitarium it's about Norman Bates when
he's in the Asylum after the events of
psycho and it's a great read and very
suspenseful oo that sounds really good
I'm going to write that down actually
because so I'm so I'm guessing it's kind
of like
between psycho one and psycho 2 cuz
psycho 2 which came out of the 80s was
when he got out of the Asylum that's a
great movie by the way so I'm going to
write that down psycho sanitar okay I
will write that down and I will
eventually read it and do a review on it
even though I have like so many I
because I wanted to do cuz remember that
I did the um review of The Joe Hill
Nolla the pram and that was one of six
uh novelas that Amazon put out for
Halloween like their Creature Feature
thing with like a bunch of big hor hor
authors and stuff and I actually checked
all of those out because they were free
so I wanted to do reviews of all of
those I read the gr Hendricks one which
I think was called the ankle biters or
something like that and that was
actually really good too so I might do a
review of that but we'll see how it goes
and I want to do some movies too because
somebody
recommended a movie called The limouse
Golem which I think was from
2017 uh they described it and I looked
it up I think it's on tub and I was like
oh man that sounds like right up my
[__] alley so I might do that and
then I also said when I was talking
about um Ponty pool that I wanted to do
a double feature of the signal and await
further instructions so I'm going to do
that at some point too but that'll take
longer because it's too movies you know
what I mean um all right so where oh I
got way behind oh I got so behind yeah
rubb and
tug it's just fun to talk about it's fun
to imagine stuff like that fantasizing
I'm just F I'm fantasizing about
going there together get the
service we're holding hands across the
table
sh Jenny's got the action cam she's
[__] recording like that well of
course I mean I they probably wouldn't
let you but like in my in my fantasy I I
would imagine that they would yeah that
they would let me yeah because I was
like oh I'm GNA film some content you
know I mean Jenny reaches her [__]
moment of [__] Revelation I'm zooming
in on like that zooming in with the
camera that's awesome no but what's
funny is
that that area we're talking about is
not the Posh areas of [__] Florida
it's really not so this it adds to the
humor okay well I think that's why real
redneck it is kind of like red the real
redneck area and ichib bomb what we're
talking about is kind of run down the
food's great it's [__] packed all
right and half them people are Yankees
in there you hear New York accents and
they're they're all retirees or old
people yeah it's a bunch of old people
you generally and big massive families
yeah I saw a family of uh cuz it's cheap
to feed a bunch of people yeah there was
there was a a family I heard him talking
they were across family of uh New York
ashkanazi Jews in there and they were
just white as they were paler than us
blue blonde hair blue eye real strong
New York Jewish accents it was like uh
the parents are probably in their I
don't know 50s and the children were
like in their 20s and they're in there
[__] just chowing down on
[__] Chinese food and just the way
they're walking around I could tell they
were they hadn't been here long yeah I
could tell tell they hadn't been here
long they were just fresh from New
England you know [__] New York you
know know I know I live there there's
there's a big difference but they were
enjoying themselves though they're like
look at this place look at these
Savages which I get it [__] funny you
know yeah I mean it is it's a different
environment it's a different yeah I mean
where we live is kind of like a
um it's a rural area for sure uh no
rural is Rish it's rural this is this is
the edge of the suburbs where we are
right now there's still Farms out here
but you go 10 miles in any direction and
there you know there's a Orlando is only
a [__] half hour away it's 28 miles
28 miles away it's half to downtown to
downtown yeah we're not far from so yeah
it's like it's a pretty quick 2 nothing
like heidleberg Mississippi where I
lived for a while where you had to go
[__] three hours to get to a city
right you know yeah it's not bad so my
my standards are a little bit different
than Jens that it reminded me though
like driving to Ichiban like last
weekend the weird remember when we
brought up that weird kitten sign yeah
there's a new one there there's a new
one like last Sun Sunday we drove to
Ichibon and I was like o I wonder if
they changed the sign now it says kitten
happy TG like Happy Thanksgiving yeah
and it was like the weekend after
Thanksgiving and I was just kind of like
whoever's doing that somebody is coming
out doing that they're dedicated they've
been doing it for more than [__] 10
years that's what I yeah we need to like
this is a whole like mystery right in
this area you got to do a whole [__]
show whoever is like whoever is doing
that
sign I don't know what it is but it's
just kind of like it's on the side of
it's in a little place called it's
called Grand Island I think that area
and it's just on the side of I think
it's um County Road
44 and it's just this sign it's a is it
chalk I don't think it's chalk is it
well because I guess it would wash off
no it's spray paint okay it's spray
paint so he must put does he put a
different sign out there every single
time no he paints over it he paints over
the sign it's like a little black sign
it's on the side of the road yeah what
he does is is that when he takes a
roller and spray paints over the the
message and then [__] spray paints
over that that's or it's probably it's
probably just a it's probably just used
a spray paint to spray black over maybe
so over the over the old script because
that'd be more efficient but it's a
black sign and it's because he's using
black spray paint probably and then the
lettering is spray
painted it looks like
kind of that brightly colored um spray
paint that you use for uh doing uh
surveying you like the survey
paint it doesn't change every week cuz
sometimes it'll be the same for you know
a week you know or three or four weeks
at a time it's in a color that's almost
neon usually yeah but it'll say it
always says kitten at the beginning but
then it'll say like something else like
so the last one said happy TG like Happy
Thanksgiving but before that it said
kitten has claws for like 3 weeks and
then prior to that it said kitten I love
you what are the other ones that we've
seen uh has claws kitten we saw K happy
birthday one yeah um kitten come home
kitten kitten has claws that's another
one um it's super weird it's just kind
of like and we can't figure out like
what why the person is doing it but
they're obviously still doing it like I
said it's like we kind of want to set up
a trail cam like on the side of the
highway and see what happens I looked it
up online and it's like there was an
article about it a few years ago because
apparently like a lot of people were
like what the [__] is that all about
because they would pass it I mean like I
said we're kind of out in a rural area
so you don't there's not like a lot of
[__] about it but other people noticed
it too but the article was so old that I
was like oh man it's been going on for
like much longer than I thought like I
said it's not changed every week but and
sometimes it says the same thing like
sometimes it goes back to an old one but
I was just kind of like I don't know
it's just weird to me because it's just
kind of you know I read and write a lot
of True Crime so my first instinct was
this is a person that their daughter or
something like that was is missing and
they're trying to like reach out to them
and it's like that's kind of what I
thought but Tom like maybe it's nothing
Sinister like that but I'm like I don't
know it just seems kind of weird like
not Sinister but I don't know it seemed
kind of weird to me so I'm always just
kind of like I don't know what the [__]
is going on there I always don't want to
know because it might it might just be
really boring but it seems creepy it
just seems creepy to
me um John Smith said yeah your loal toy
be til's mystery yeah that's exactly
what it is and it's like I don't even
remember when we first noticed it
because whenever we first first started
driving to
Ichiban um I was like oh look at that
sign and I don't even remember what it
said the first time but then it's just
like we started noticing it like every
time we passed it I'm like sometimes it
said something different and I was just
kind of like what the what is that like
what is that all about and there's no
I'm sure there's a house back there but
you can't see it you know what I mean
it's just it's this house it's the sign
and it's like on the side of the highway
and there's kind of a trail but and I'm
sure there's a house back there but you
can't really see it you know you know
what I mean so it's like I don't know if
the person that lives back there is
doing it or I don't know it's weird but
they've been doing it for a long time
evidently according to this according to
the article because when did I say the
article was
from a few years ago and they said at
that point that it had been going on for
like 10 years 10 11 years at least like
people had started noticing it so it's
somebody that has been doing this for
like a really long time and they're
still changing it yeah because they just
changed it like last week
yeah Allison said it's a weird story
yeah it is weird it is weird I don't get
the kitten has claws thing I think
that's the most common one that we've
seen yeah cuz it's almost kind of like
he reverts to or whoever it is that's
doing it like reverts to that when he
can't think of anything else it looks
like a man's handwriting if you ask me I
I pictured it as a man yeah yeah I
pictured it as a man what what's people
saying um Allison said it was a weird
story uh oh and they're talking about
Allison said she was an old person from
New York from Queens okay and then uh
she said Queens accent and I think like
Bryce who's from New Zealand yeah uh
said oh you speak the Queens when I was
a kid the woman that taught me English
wanted me to speak the Queens she was
strict about that so yeah like joking
about that and then Allison said I watch
East Enders what do I know that's pretty
funny that accent sticks out like a sore
thomb in Florida it's just diametrically
a [__] opposite of [__] everything
that here it's just it's ridiculous well
there are a lot of New Yorkers here
though because I mean and that's been
true ever since I was a kid what's funny
is that I'll go down it's hot down here
like they move down here when they
retire because the weather's nice and
it's not only New Yorkers it's people
from Canada I go down to the Oasis and
they got some of their regulars who are
in there every [__] day are from
Canada and New
York and just these [__] Canadian
accents and [__] New York
accents I kind of feel sorry for the
guys warlock's motorcycle club goes in
there [__] kind of bullies him a
little bit you know I me [__] heard
one guy goes hey if I ever catch you
play he if I ever C what was that
band if I ever catch you playing new
Young on that [__] jukebox again I'm
beating a [__] out of you he okay all
right that's like I said like
yeah that's some old school [__] that's
some old school [__] there yeah that's
like that's like my grandpa yeah you
ever played Neil Young on there beat the
[__] out of you yeah yeah so I'm
surprised like people are still like
yeah they're old guys but you know
they're they're bikers man fcking you
know those guys were but actually those
dudes weren't that old though they would
have known they were in their 50s yeah
that's just old enough to know if you
guys know what I'm talking about is
that there was a big war between Neil
Young and Leonard skinnard
back in the day Leonard skard yeah I
don't really like Leonard skin i'
actually like Neil Young's music a
little bit better Leonard skinnard was
kind of [__] annoying you know but
Neil Young was a yane and [__]
Leonard Skinner was Southern as [__] and
they got into a big beef over [__] uh
the north south
thing and
uh and some people here still remember
it now in that particular case
I don't think I don't think that had
much to do with the actual beef between
those bands I think it was just the fact
that warlock's motorcycle club are
Southerners and they or at least this
branches that's down here and they just
do not like the fact
that Northerners are moving
here so when they go to a motorcycle
this is only in a motorcycle bar
basically this is a biker bar okay and
when bikers come when these motorcycle
gang guys come into biker bars they kind
of they kind of run it you
know and in that particular
case if I ever hey if I ever hear you
play a Neil Young in here again I'm G
beat the [__] out of you he's C [__]
funny but you know what's the guy GNA
say there's like [__] seven or eight
of them in there you know when that
happens
[__]
Oasis I like going I like visiting the
Oasis I just can't really [__] hang
out at the Oasis man [__] I can't
believe like after a while about
southern man after all of these decades
after a while I just like [__] going
like C can't take this [__] music
anymore God it's horrible I can't take
this [__] music I got to go well
remember when we went down there the
other day well it was a couple weeks ago
yeah biker friend of mine and a girl ex
kind of friend female friend of mine
yeah our friend Melissa was down there
with her boyfriend they and they ride
bikes and they were on their way to
Daytona right yeah they were going to
bike week they were going to bike week
and they stopped at the Oasis and we
went down there and met them and man the
music in there it get to you after a
while I was just kind of like man it's
the middle of the afternoon and I don't
want to get drunk but I kind of do want
to get drunk because I got to deal with
this [__] they even started playing
like some new country and I was just
kind of like Jesus [__] Christ it's
like going back to
1991 it's like if you're going to play
country can you at least play some good
[__] like old [__] like Johnny Cash or
Hank Williams or something God damn well
it's just kind that new country is just
kind of crappy music it's a vile
yeah when I go in there though you and
that the juke box is App application
operated off off your [__]
tablet you can pay for [__] and [__]
you can even pay more to get your music
moved up there's all kinds of games you
can play on that [__] you can you can
like drop your dick on people yeah I
play metal in there yeah I got more
money than you so I can play my music
yeah when I go on I play a lot of
classic metal or motohead or um I kind
of feel like people probably wouldn't
object to that no they listen to it yeah
that's listen to it who doesn't love
Motorhead yeah come on and then I [__] I
went on I started DJ and the [__] cost
you to DJ too but I started DJ and and
[__] um uh the bartenders the chicks
were [__] loving it I I went on a
whole [__] um I went on a whole
[__]
007 [__] theme [__] playlist love
that yeah World is Not Enough [__] uh
[__] View to a Kill I did all the
some of the new you for real like played
Durant Durant in there yeah like I was
in there before when you played the
Chris Cornell Yeah Yeah Chris Cornell
one [__] um and I played the one the
White Stripes ones with [__] from SAU
played that in there uh which [__]
was Alicia Keys and the dude from and
the dudes from The White Stripes that's
a [__] great theme song so I did dou
7 themes but uh I played some cure in
there and those girls all even old the
old song was it I played Boys Don't Cry
Oh okay and that's old one yeah and
[__] some of them girls are age
they're not girls they're women those
women in there [__] oh you play they
love they immediately knew what that was
see they don't really listen to that
[__] that those dudes are requested they
actually they liked more new old dudes
are kind of they get kind of aifi
they're aifi in that
[__] so I started playing chick music
they [__] [__] girls were loving it
played Petty and pink I played I played
the you play like Pedic first I no I
played the Billy Idol cover of pretty
and pink he did a cover of pretty and
pink oh yeah it's good it's really good
that I thought you play like the same
first version no the pretty pretty and
pink actually was uh going to be a Billy
Idol song no it wasn't yeah it was he
didn't buy it and it got sent to the it
got you're thinking of that simple mind
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know what you're talking about yeah that
was a simp don't you forget about yeah
that was simple that was yeah simple cuz
I was going to say Psychedelic Furs yeah
wrote Pretty in Pink it came out on it
came out on their album in 1981 yeah it
wasn't pretty big it was don't you
forget about me that's what I played
pretty and pink actually the movie was
based on the song and the Psychedelic
Furs did another version of the song in
1985 to put in the movie but the I
actually like the original 1981 version
better it's a little it's a rougher like
more Punky yeah I made a mistake yeah
yeah I was like sitting there going
umn Don't You Forget About Me yeah okay
the Billy Idol version of right which is
good I actually it's good yeah real good
yeah because don't you forget about me
the simple Mind song yeah was actually
given to Billy Idol first but he he
liked it he didn't want to do it no he
he wanted well he did a version of it
but he did a version of it much later
yeah much much later like I think in the
2000s or maybe the the 90 late 90s he
liked it at the time but uh his
management and stuff said that that song
was kind of soft that that might have
been a little too soft for his
image so he took their advice but he he
said that he always kind of doubted that
that that was the right thing to do that
he probably should have done that song
I'm sorry but that's a great song yeah
but that was offered to him so he did in
it's a great he did another one instead
I don't remember which one it was Zach
says now I wonder is country medal a
thing yeah every country everything is a
thing country medal is a thing although
it probably shouldn't be but the best if
you ask me what the best
Southern retro country medal band of all
time was from
Wales it's called Nazareth was it Wales
or Scotland I thought they were Scottish
they might have been Scotland Yeah man
they had me fooled since I was a little
kid listening I say little kid I was a
teenager jamming to Nazareth and I
thought they were Southern as [__] no
man this [__] was from [__]
Scotland I had uh no mean the album no
mean City then the hair of the dog
[__] album this is just it was like a
southern version of ACDC it kind of had
a it had a real hard southern rock sound
to it for to us we thought it was I
thought it was a lot better than Molly
Hatchet but I'm not well mol hatch
[__] suck I don't like Molly hatch
but that was like real that was Southern
right but the the I don't know if they
intended that to have a Southern Sound
but it sure as [__] did no I'm sure they
did well because here's the thing um
particularly during that era and even
into the 19s 80s I'm just talking about
like the late 70s early 1980s a lot of
British and Australian bands even ones
that were Post Punk or something like
that were fascinated by the American
South yeah okay so a lot of them tried
to well and even bands like the Rolling
Stones and stuff like that were trying
to replicate the sound of like Southern
Blues wildes is what they were trying to
replicate Wild Horses so a lot of them
were into that well like I said this
kind of more in my wheelhouse look at
somebody like the birthday party with
caves old band who were Australian he
loved old Southern Blues um and so that
that informed like a lot of their sound
yeah it doesn't sound like Blues really
it sounds like I I don't even know how I
describe it actually but it does have
like a
blues um influence to it and like when
he went solo like a lot of his later
stuff was like very Blues influenced and
he did a lot of Blues covers also that
was pre- internet era you know 80s you
know mid 80s I'm jamming out the [__]
nazareth's [__] no mean City album
got the damn alien on the cover great
lyrics and I'm thinking man these
[__] are tight man they sound
good it's kind of like a real hard ACDC
but with kind of a psychedelic almost
kind of like a little bit of a deep
purple kind of sound to
it and [__]
Southern and I'm like man these
[__] must be from
Alabama
not no they're from [__] like
Scotland sh somewhere and I think I
think they I think they're extinct I
think every one of those guys is dead by
now yeah maybe so but it was a good band
I haven't heard it in a long time i' had
to go revisit that and see if it see if
it stood the test of time but back in
those days I [__] thought it was
awesome Victor said I think it's funny
when people hear say Texas is full stop
moving here and you click on their
Facebook and they're originally from
Missouri or some [__] yeah I mean you
know that happens a lot in Florida
because people are like hey don't move
here to Florida I'm like [__] you
weren't even born here I was born here
okay I can tell people to [__] up I
don't I don't though Southerners are all
Southern though but I'm just saying
right don't pretend like you were born
in Florida my ass was born in Florida I
was born right in Daytona Beach Halifax
Hospital [__] and there has
always been
migration within the southern states and
out of the southern states yeah and it
just seems dumb to like it's always been
going on make to to kind of focus a
large part of your identity around that
I feel like well some some families have
been here for Generations yeah and I get
that in the South for Generations yeah I
get like my my mother's family was
actually originally from Virginia going
back to the
1800s uh this is my this was with my
granddad who ended up working for
McDonald Douglas and [__] you know he
was he was he was a [__] aerospace
engineer he worked for all kinds he
worked on the [__] Saturn project
I've already bragged about this [__]
anyway um he they ended up moving to
California like in the early 60s late
50s but they were
Southern but you wouldn't know it
talking to them you know what I mean
[__] not really
and my mom and all her sisters were born
in California but the family was a
southern family now a lot of them have
moved back in the South most of them and
then some of them actually moved to the
Middle East which was a long story
because they they married military guys
who got jobs ex-military guys who got
jobs as like hel helicopter pilots and
bodyguards in Qatar and uh [__] Dubai
and [__] their ex Task Force 160 Special
Operations Aviation guys Frost cw3 Frost
he was my UNC my uncle and he had a
brother they were both in that task
force 160 and they're both in the Middle
East uh so a southern family doesn't
necessarily mean it's in the South some
of them are [__] spread out across
the [__] world I mean I lived in Miss
I lived in [__] Brazil for a while
[__] Egypt
Korea
my dad's side of the family are from
Springfield Tennessee that's where my
grandparents were from that's where my
dad was born my mom's side of the family
are from Baltimore Maryland but they
moved down here before I was
born um but like I said I was born in
Florida in Daytona Beach uh Allison says
Tom and Jenny have you seen velvet gold
mine yes I love that [__] movie I
love that [__] movie I don't think
we've have we reviewed it no oh maybe we
should should I have I have it somewhere
F gold mine was the one that was kind of
like Iggy Pop and David Bowie right yeah
but like fictional fic good for I love
that it also had like a fictionalized
version of like Sid Barrett from [__]
Yeah Yeah from pck Floyd he was in it
which was a great that's a great idea
for like movie we got to see that again
I know I love that movie I love that
movie it's so good yeah and I don't
think we've ever reviewed it maybe we
should do that I might have it I think I
I thought I had it somewhere but I'm
sure can find it if I don't have got all
kinds of comments goe and see what
they're say I know hold on was um yeah
they're talking about like uh zezy top
Camp guy like zezy top zezy top yeah no
I'm not a fan but you know yeah it was a
little too Poppy for me in a way I me it
it did kind it was like fake Southern
[__] but you know I tell you what that
was popular in the South when I was when
I was well it still is still is it still
is Victor said my family founded the
town of benavites Texas we didn't cross
the border the Border crossed us okay
yeah that's how that happened yeah Zach
says Dad side are from Northeast Indiana
and mom was born in South Dakota but
grew up in Louisiana Louisiana yeah yeah
I mean I'm a fan of Louisiana all of my
cousins live there they're all cages
well you lived there for a while yeah I
live there I've never been we've always
said we were going to go one of these
days CU I've never been call The Dirty
South yeah it's I just want to go there
and eat my way through the whole entire
city it's not as good as it used to be
but that's okay yeah I didn't get to go
like during it Hayday so you know what I
mean
I'll take what I can get best of the
[__] bdan what's his name Paul bdan
is that is it Anthony bdan Anthony B no
no not Anthony Paul PD PA Pome that's
who you're talking about best of the
Paul Pome
era Cajun food actually comes out of
people's kitchens that's you know I'm
sure there's a few restaurants out there
but they're going to be constantly
changing you know what I mean they're
going to be in business for a few years
and then go out you'd have to see what
the what the the what the scene is like
right now and it wouldn't be in the
French Quarter of course that's tour of
[__] probably find some really good [__]
around Slidell mety that kind of [__]
Slidell probably probably could be a
good bet it's more Suburban it's the
smaller town outside of New Orleans
probably real good restaurants there
with decent prizes with Old
School culinary experience you know Zach
said we were there March of last year
and oh my God it's still so pretty down
there yeah yeah Tom hasn't been in a
while yeah been a long time since I've
been there it's been a long time well
like I said we've been talking about we
need to do a trip one of these days
we've never really done a real uh we've
been together 13 years never been
anywhere and we've never really been on
like a big trip any place working paying
for [__] yeah can't really afford it
like I said I went to St Augustine but I
went by myself like for a few days but
that was kind of kind of like that's
pretty much it you went to Mississippi
to visit your dad for two weeks that was
about it we don't really go anywhere
we've been to Universal Studios for a
day that was about it we never like went
on any trips we just go to the club yeah
pretty
much Victor said y'all should come to
San
Antonio maybe we
should I don't know there's lots of
places I want to go there's lots of
places I just never had any money you
know never any money I never had any
time I got to put I got a [__] uh
send a message to uh
Melissa ask her what if anything's going
on in in uh in New Orleans because I
mean that's drivable
yeah yeah you could drive that not with
the car we have now well no I would rent
a car probably I we' buy another car
that car is on its way out anyway it is
yeah but um drive up and see Melissa and
then uh go
uh go to the French
Quarter see I would love that think that
I think that would be fun if they've got
anything going on in the French Quarter
any goth clubs we'll see they used to
used to be the
crystal the Crystal and the [__]
Convent or the H con it was another one
yeah Crystal the convent hellfire club
was another one but it didn't last
long just got to see what's going on on
there yeah a lot of them don't like last
all that long although I will say that
our one of our Premier goth clubs here
in Central Florida which is the castle
in Tampa I believe just celebrated
its
32nd year 33rd I can't remember they
were having like a big party for
it but yeah so I can't believe that
place has been there as long as it has
cuz like I said they normally don't last
all that long although
iar where we go it's or Barbarella as
it's called now that was there for 30
something years it's not in the same
place but I mean it's still the same
Club pretty much it's just like in a
different location now but it's been
there I don't even remember when they
opened cuz I remember going there when I
was younger you know what I mean so
that's been there a long time which like
I said is
unusual you know normally have one it's
there for like a year or two and then it
folds or something because there's it
it's usually like not a big enough scene
to maintain it you know but every now
and then you do kind of look into
something uh what's the French Quarter
oh it's a very famous area in New
Orleans Louisiana that's kind of where
all the tourists go um you know that's
where when everybody thinks of New
Orleans that's what they think of that's
like the main tourist area it's like you
know go you go there for Marty gr and
all that kind of stuff you know like I
said um Tom lived in he didn't live in
New Orleans New Orleans but he lived
like close enough that he could drive
there like for clubs and
stuff and let me
see yeah Bryce was asking what the
French Quarter was what you don't know
what the French Quarter is because he's
from new he's from New Zealand all right
in in New in New
Orleans there's an area called the
French Quarter which is the French
neighborhood it's got round Esplanade
and everything is one of the main drags
there it's where
it's been there forever you know but uh
recently that's where Marilyn Manson and
[__] the dude that [__] Trent
resner lived right outside the French
Quarter on Esplanade I believe it was
they had a house there lot of [__] was
like said if you read an rice or poy Z
Brite or something like that like a lot
of vampire Chronicles a lot was set
there yeah it's been the French Quarter
it's got some old architecture but it's
nothing but
bars bars and shops and clubs and people
walking around then there's Bourbon
Street that's like the main
drag and you're going to see some wild
[__] there now they
got a lot of topless [__] J Migra
they're throwing beads around but I was
never really into that tourist stuff I
was hanging out in the golf club down
near um what was the name of the
place remember the road that that was
near ah it doesn't matter now it's been
a long time I could find it but I forgot
what the name
was decar Street around there that's
where I used to hang
out and they were kind of hole in
thewall gritty clubs old old buildings
you know some of them 1700s 1800s bricks
brick buildings A lot of
them and
uh for a tourist area very dangerous
you'd have a lot of cops there but
people got shot they got killed there
you get you get robbed it's in the
middle of the [__] Hood the hood
surrounds it and they come in there and
[__] rob you and
[__] so much more dangerous than say New
York you know [__] New York almost I
walked around New York City all day and
all night long and like I never had
anything I lived in Detroit saw some
rats but that was about it I lived in
lived in Detroit on on [__] second
West Hancock near [__] cast
Corridor and that was the murder capital
of the [__] world during the time I
was there and I never had any problem in
Detroit you have all kinds of problems
in a French Quarter you gonna go to
French Quarter when you're when you were
me back in those days you were going to
have to fight to defend your [__] you
know you're going to run a lot of people
there are not from there it's a lot of
they're drunk and they're acting
crazy and then you got predatory [__]
criminals that go in there to try to
[__] rob people jump out cuz they
know that people aren't from there yeah
they know they're not from
there now I will hand it to uh NPD
New Orleans Police Department they put
their best cops in there to protect
the the you know but they can't be
everywhere at once yeah sure rest of the
NOP nopd a lot of them are just [__] I
mean they're recruited from the normal I
mean they had NPD guys getting [__]
on death row for [__] doing multiple
murders and [__] robberies and [__]
one of them was a woman an nopd woman
who went in with her gangster boyfriend
and [__] robbed the place and [__]
move M him into the [__] freezer
Walkin freezer and shot
him and her boyfriend was like 16 and
she's like [__] 25 it's [__] crazy
[__] uh it's just a a dangerous place
but there's something about that danger
that made it
exciting you
know and uh tourists everywhere you know
it's almost kind of has like a casino
style atmosphere mixed with like the
wild west that's was the French Quarter
back in the time I was there in the '90s
late '90s mid to late 90s someh would
go well we were having all kinds of goth
events down there man we'd have [__]
convergence we had convergence down
there I think that was 8 huge that was
like one of the biggest goth things in
the country took over all of [__]
decer Street yeah they had it every year
yeah and they were from all over the
world man had [__] Gods from Germany
yeah people would come from everywhere
like to go to that one event like
because it was annual and that was deep
in the an rice era man [__] they all
had vampire fangs and cutest [__] and
[__] man [__] was sexy that's where I
met my first
wife which she was cute too man [__]
you know [__] um but we weren't
together long year or so couple
years um but
that's that's what the French Quarter
was is I haven't been there in a long
time but it hasn't changed because it it
was it's always been that way it's been
there for hundreds of
years
because
even before there was a United States
there was a New Orleans you know it was
French first it was Spanish and then it
was
French and then it got purchased in the
Louisiana Purchase in the 1700s so it
was just always there it was a pirate it
was a Pirate Cove it was a pirate
City literally yeah literally Pirates
well kind of like Tampa was yeah like
Tampa right that's why they still have
gasp barill like the big Pirate festival
every year cuz it's right on the Gulf of
Mexico you know what I mean yeah Bryce
asked uh interesting do they speak
French no uh I got cousins that live
there they've been there for forever I
guess and they're Cajun and they have a
different accent you know uh kind of a
French and they have French names part
of my name is French my middle name is
Francis fris yeah it's I mean related
with all that well there's a dialect
Creole yeah Creole which is like a it's
like a pigeon what they call a pigeon
pigeon English of French and English
it's like a French English hybrid kind
of so you do hear like some oldtimers
like speaking that yeah that's very rare
now though very rare yeah you don't hear
it much anymore I kind of feel like
that's kind of more an old person
cun cinjun are country Creole Creole are
kind of like City people they're the
same people Cajun and creole are the
same thing a Cajun is a country version
of a creole now the real redneck version
of a is a [__] ass all right [__] ass
and it comes from a French word that
sounds like Kun I think is what it's
called it called [__] ass it just it
means fool red deck fool yeah yeah like
that yeah it could also mean [__]
though too dirty [__] that's another
interpretation of what they're talking
about those dirty [__] we like dirty
hor is
yeah that's just it's kind of
interesting cuz you know like like I
said Bryce is from New Zealand he's on
the other side of world so it's like so
he wouldn't really know like that's like
pretty awesome yeah but yeah they
usually I have heard like old people in
Louisiana speaking that kind of like you
can still understand what they're saying
but sometimes you need kind of yeah you
need kind of translation kind of sounds
like this here there and then in some
areas it almost sounds like something
from New York they do a little bit of
that because there is there was a new
New York influence on um New Orleans uh
a lot of New York gangsters left New
York to [__] open up business in New
Orleans so it's a fascinating place to
be
honest I'm trying to [__] get to our
show on this but for some reason it's
not going too hopefully we're still good
huh well everybody's still talking
nobody is like saying anything that
we're not so all right I will note
though that is
918 okay yeah we got we got to so should
we wrap it up probably need to yeah we
got to start getting ready head out
toward yep the bar all right well uh
thank you for uh speaking with us and we
will uh close this show down you all had
to party and we got a party and we we
talked you in to this weekend yeah have
a good weekend this PE people now Monday
we're probably going to do Haunting in
Georgia okay yeah and Haunting in
Georgia or Laing in Connecticut 2 Ghosts
of Georgia all right so we do a
paranormal show yeah same thing we did
last week but with the with the Georgia
yeah and and too bad people didn't show
up for the didn't show up for a live
stream not many people we didn't get
many hits on that either I don't know if
it was maybe they didn't understand what
we were doing or what but normally
paranormal shows are quite popular but
that last one we did not not many people
watched it did you notice that like no I
it was like 200 well we're still going
to do the other one because we're going
to do it yeah maybe maybe maybe it'll
catch on yeah well we'll find out how
cuz we're doing extra shows yeah and I
might do some more shows although it
might I might have to wait till Tuesday
because I got like a bunch of movies and
[__] I like I gotta watch but uh but
yeah so thanks everybody for dropping by
this evening thanks for all your super
chats uh have a good weekend y'all and
we will see you again on Monday night
good